[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel le boulanger l'auteur de
l'Histoire de l'En Avant Guingamp depuis
1912 et qu'il vient de publier aux
éditions à la bargane n'a peut-être pas
tort d'écrire
page 171 que le sport ici fut appelé au
chevet d'une économie malade et que
lorsque le meilleur club amateur de
France passe un professionnel voici un
peu plus de 10 ans ce fut une belle
revanche pour Guingamp dont le nom a
signifie pour des générations de Breton
conseil de révision uniforme et caserne
et ce petit club des Côtes-d'Armor
régionalement redouté et bien a fait
telle ascension avec des huitièmes de
finale de Coupe de France une accession
deuxième division puis en première
division que ça vaut la peine d'être
1912 c'est la date qui figure sur l'acte
de naissance de l'En Avant Guingamp mais
c'est exactement 60 ans plus tard en 72
que le club se révèle à la France
entière un jeune industriel de 30 ans
Noël le Greg prend en main ce petit club
des Côtes du Nord qui végètent en
division supérieure régionale c'est le
décollage l'En Avant bouscule la
hiérarchie en Coupe de France Lamballe
est avalé au cinquième tour puis les
Guingampais renvoient coup sur coups
leurs études trois équipes de deuxième
division l'aval de Buzyn au sixième tour
Brest de Buzyn également et Le Mans
quatre buzza 2 en 32e de finale l'En
Avant fait alors la une de tous les
quotidiens nationaux les caméras et les
micros se tournent vers cette petite
commune jusque-là inconnue Guingamp est
en 16e de finale le tirage au sort offre
encore une pointure au joueur de Noël le
grec Lorient club de 3e division c'est
le stade de l'armoricaine à Brest qui
accueille ce choc qui passionne toute la
Bretagne le Finistère se teinte de rouge
et noir des carres entiers de supporters
se déversent dans la rade
le vieux pépère c'est son surnom dans
son café il va même de s'en pronostic
quel est votre
pronostics
les amateurs guingampés piétine Lorient
et s'impose de Buzyn
[Applaudissements]
les héros s'appellent André et Le Quéré
André commerçant dans le civil s'il le
premier but
[Applaudissements]
il en avait déjà réussi trois au tour
précédent face au Mans
[Applaudissements]
Le Quéré quant à lui professeur de son
état parachève le travail et donne la
leçon à la défense morbihanaise qui ne
sait plus où aller et si l'épopée de
l'En Avant s'achève au tour suivant face
à Rouen qui évolue en première division
Guingamp n'en a pas moins inscrit l'une
des plus belles pages de l'histoire de
la Coupe de France
[Applaudissements]
dans la foulée de son expo en couple en
avant gravit les échelons du football
français une vitesse inouée 1976 les
Bretons sont en deuxième division dont
ils seront pendant 17 ans l'un des
piliers 93 la réorganisation du
championnat est fatale en avant reléguée
en nationalin arrive Francis merreck il
entraîneur qui va relancer ses équipes
le club retrouve aussitôt la D2 et le 27
mai 95 c'est l'apothéose au Roudourou ce
but de Claude Michel face à Toulouse
permet au guingampé de rejoindre l'élite
du football français la première
division et d'emblée les joueurs du
président Salomon si son confortablement
installés des jouants tous les
pronostics une nouvelle page s'ouvre
mais ça c'est une autre histoire
bonjour Noël le Great bonjour je me
demande qui vous préféreriez que je
salue en vous le maire de Guingamp le
président de la Ligue nationale de
football l'industriel du surgelé ou bien
l'ancien président longtemps de l'En
Avant Guingamp on fera tout simplement
le gangaa à Céline qui a certes quelques
quelques fonctions mais qui se plaît
beaucoup à Guingamp qui aime vivre ici
qui ont envie de faire quelque chose
d'intéressant également vous ne m'avez
pas vraiment répondu alors je vais poser
la question autrement comme mère de
Guingamp vous êtes tenu à un certain
équilibre entre le football et le reste
et comme président de la ligue vous ne
pouvez pas préférer En Avant Guingamp
malheureusement peut-être côté cœur
soyons clairs on peut pas trop tricher
il est bien bien évident que le côté
cœur et très sensible pour pour Guingamp
on peut pas à la fois être né ici et on
va passer sa vie dans ce club et de mer
et ne pas avoir le côté fictif ceci dit
lorsqu'on a des décisions nationales à
prendre si on ça Guingamp à tout moment
vous savez les autres vous le rappelle
vivement et je crois que c'est pas
largement franchi oui j'ai un plaisir
important est au stade mais je me sens
bien dans la peau d'un président de le
livre l'instrument comme je le ressens
avec passion la mission qui m'a été
confiée et le maire à ceux qui
s'intéresse pas trop au football
qu'est-ce qu'il me dit
le maire peut dire enfin ceux qui
n'aiment pas que le football est pour la
ville de Guingamp une belle vitrine ah
oui ça c'est vrai je crois que ça donne
mon côté à côté sympathique qui est
indéniable c'est une passion c'est une
envie de gagner une envie de se
surpasser alors il peut y avoir beaucoup
de projets autour de ses idées mais en
tout cas c'est pour la ville de Guingamp
un phénomène plutôt très positif lorsque
vous avez dû commencer à rassembler un
peu de moyens vous avez dû remuer du
monde conseil général les sponsors
aussi des années vous savez plus
simplement qu'on imagine il y a toujours
eu des performances ça coupe de France
en 72 73 nous a nous a aidé le sport
nous a souvent aidés en fait à
convaincre lorsqu'on a une bonne
performances on a quelques fois des
difficultés sportives l'année suivante
parce que les départs de jeunes joueurs
amateurs étaient nombreux mais le
Conseil général c'est vrai les
entreprises quand vous regardez ces
panneaux c'est 90%
des entreprises du département donc il y
a un attachement il y a une fidélité
importante alors le budget du club est
passé je regarde mes chiffres on a de
quelques centaines de milliers de francs
dans les années 60
5 millions et demi en 83 12 millions 92
et à 34 millions et demi je crois en
actuellement
40 millions bon est-ce que vous ne
risquez pas un jour de répéter ce que
vous avez dit
en vous montrant très fort j'accuse
l'argent de pourrir le football non
parce que Guingamp ici
[Musique]
je crois cette philosophie avec les
dirigeants qui sont mes amis on a
travaillé durement pour mettre ce club
en place et l'équipe de dirigeants
actuels Salomon qui a pris le relais
dirige merveilleusement l'esclave avec
les amis qui étaient qui étaient déjà en
place Guingamp n'a jamais dépensé un
centime de plus que ce qu'il avait donc
ça c'est tout à fait clair et un gant de
fera jamais dedans on prend ne dira
jamais voir ses copains pour arracher
des des sommes qui ne pourraient pas
rembourser mais pas de caisse noire là
dessous
diriger ce club tout le temps avec cette
rigueur c'est à dire qu'on a mis on
connaît les sommes c'est-à-dire le club
de football ça se gère je lui ai dit
depuis tout le temps discours on connaît
parfaitement à quelque chose près en
tout cas notre budget avant de démarrer
une saison contrairement à ce que disait
certains illusionnistes ils avaient les
recettes de football c'est quoi les
contrats de pub les endroits Télévisions
la subvention alors qu'est-ce qui bouge
un peu c'est le guichet oui c'est ça
vous faites une très bonne saison vous
avez à Guingamp en première division 10
000 de moyenne vous faites une saison
moyenne vous avez 7000 de voyage
ça joue mais pas beaucoup donc on peut
se tromper c'est une un certain
pourcentage mais pas énormément
alors ce club fut créé par des
instituteurs laïques et
aujourd'hui ce sont d'autres industriels
après vous qui prennent qui prennent les
reines le foot qui était donc un sport
éducatif c'est quand même devenu ici
aussi une entreprise pour l'équipe a
c'est évident que c'est une entreprise
lorsqu'on parle de 40 millions de
budgets c'est déjà une très belle
affaire qui est en milieu il y en a pas
beaucoup à Guingamp de schiste à faire
400 millions il y en a presque pas quand
je réfléchis bien c'est peut-être l'une
des plus belles affaires guingampès en
chiffres donc c'est effectivement c'est
une entreprise mais ceci dit il n'y a
pas de l'équipage dans un club comme
Guingamp il y a 300 licenciés les
instits sont toujours là les profs aussi
les bénévoles nombreux et je crois que
la philosophie est bien assez en place
une chorale magnifique là on l'a vu hier
soir mais c'est fou ça c'est vraiment le
succès de nouvelles équipes
je crois que ils ont réussi à sauter une
génération en fait lorsque j'ai pris le
club à 30 ans comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure ce qui émerve Avant de Guingamp
avait déjà 40 ans
et forcément comme une absence de
résultats quelques temps il y avait à
côté sympathique mais aujourd'hui grâce
à ses efforts des gens il y a quelques
jeunes du lycée Pavilly il y a 2000
gosses ou Jeanne qui entre 16 et 20 ans
alors vous allez agrandir le stade là il
y a un quartier ici c'est le quartier du
Roudourou fausse quartier défavorisée
disons-le balle football pour les jeunes
c'est un peu un exutoire c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est bien présent dans
leur vie je crois que c'est bien d'avoir
fait ici il était un moment et on se
posait des questions ou refaire le stade
je vous coupe parce que nous avons
là-dessus un reportage d'Aline Mortamet
sur le quartier du Roudourou
le Roudourou trois syllabes
emblématiques pour une équipe qui gagne
et symbole exemplaire d'un quartier qui
se tourne délibérément vers le foot
depuis qu'en avant est rentré dans la
grande cour de l'ADN le ballon rond a
retrouvé tous ces titres de nos blessés
de rêves dans ce quartier réputé
difficile ou le chômage rouge aux
alentours de chaque hall d'immeuble les
gamins consacre le maximum de leur temps
aux entraînements pour ressembler aux
grands Gravelines Hugues Guivarch ou
corridon autant de noms d'idole qui
génère autant d'appétit de champion
certainement être un peu un peu comme
plus tard quoi je pense que par rapport
aux gamins qui sont sur la cité ça
apporte beaucoup on voit même les
enfants sur 17h qui commence à venir
voir au stade si les joueurs sont là et
tout ils sont vraiment des mordus
quelques-uns qui sont morts ils sont
déjà en shorts en maillot
alors autre chose on parle beaucoup de
l'Europe la circulation des hommes comme
circulation des idées alors ça m'amène à
la question suivante combien
restera-t-il de Bretons dans cette
équipe au moment où les frontières
s'ouvriront complètement pour le
football je suis pas très inquiet pour
pour le sport national et l'ouverture on
peut pas à la fois si vous voulez être
partisan de l'Europe en ce qui concerne
l'économie et puis lorsqu'on a une
activité qui est sportive vouloir la
protéger et la fermer la libre
concurrence
installer en Europe je pense qu'on a une
avance en ce qui concerne la formation
la France en général la France de
football et je vois mal d'une équipe
comme Guingamp demain recruter 5 jeunes
allemands ou 5 italiens et trois anglais
je crois qu'il faut pas changer sa vie
en fait on peut l'améliorer mais si elle
est racine sont importantes dans
l'équipe hier soir il y avait la moitié
de l'équipe qui a fait ses études à
Guingamp qui a été formé à Guingamp qui
dans la famille habite Guingamp je crois
qu'on peut pas tuer ces racines ce
serait grave erreur ça c'est parole
seront retenues parfait on regardera ça
pendant 2000 on en reparlera merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Maire
et Monsieur l'ancien président de l'on
avait en Guingamp vous pourrez toujours
cette étiquette j'espère
[Musique]